i'm rachel campos in for laura ingram
and this is a special edition of the
ingram angle from new york city tonight
we finally got it the trump raid
affidavit look it's all black it's right
here but of course it only brought us
more questions than answers and that
could be exactly how they wanted it
because then it leads to conversations
like this
let's start with the biggest revelations
from uh the more questions david yeah so
a lot of really introductory intricately
startling details the devil is in the
details and donald trump had no
let's start with the big reason no um
to retain those documents at mar-a-lago
so a lot of really interesting
there could be new not just donald trump
as well as additional crimes that could
be charged
is she kidding me she might be getting
an idea from one of the small parts of
the affidavit that was curiously left
unredacted like on page 30 where it
referred to president trump and those
around him as quote criminal parties but
still didn't provide any evidence to
prove it it also warned that releasing
the affidavit would give trump and his
team the opportunity to flee or destroy
evidence stored electronically and
otherwise
flee
really
trump's plane has his name on it and
destroy electronic evidence do they mean
doing something like i don't know
deleting 33 000 emails we're going to
get into that more in moments with our
legal panel but if anyone thinks that
the doj is an impartial actor this whole
sordid affair should put that to rest
the affidavit alleges that there was
probable cause to believe that evidence
of obstruction was going to be found at
mar-a-lago
all right then let's see it
do the documents released today support
that well there's a lot of allegations
here but where's the actual evidence
and we keep asking this but what the
heck took so long to execute this raid
if it was such an urgent matter of
national security why did it take so
long
they got a subpoena in june then a
search warrant in august and then three
days after that they finally marched in
think about it it's actually really
concerning that the doj waited so long
if there was such an immediate risk to
our national security
trump was out of office for over 500
days by the time the raid happened his
team had already been in talks with the
national archives and the fbi for months
and months
back in february the archivists of the
united states even told congresswoman
maloney in a letter that they had
already gotten 15 boxes from trump so
again we have a lot of questions and
pretty minimal answers hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else